olá a todos o aqui quem fala é mudar que
sejam muito bem vindos
é mais um vídeo e o estrago já que as
top 10 publicidade os mais assustadores
do mundo não sei se vocês perceberam é
hoje vamos assistir às disputas cidades
mais assustadores de sempre muitas já
foram banidas por que pé está muito
assustador sua luta que sozinho no
estúdio não pára nem lá fora ela agora
está tudo vazio são quatro delas 14 em
12 também é é eu ficar sem voz não só eu
acho que é um sinal divino e possui a
dizer vai pra comandar que só vai dormir
mas não estou que gravar em natal o meu
caminho tomar gosto de usar nem liso o
meu querido já tavira e este ano em azul
que bosta eu voltei pintar o estopim
para tudo para tudo para todos vocês diz
em cuidar que não dava aos inscritos o
deco não quer nada o nosso daqueles
visualizações mentira hoje eu vou te dar
uma prenda não mudar são vocês comprar
mas que eu vou anunciar uma prenda que
vocês podem receber a partir de hoje
vocês podem encontrar um pack de
playstation com dois jogos lá na final é
o sinal que também viu uma mensagem o
bar crise os seus inscritos que o canal
é um lixo até como assim como a fimca
reparem só vocês podem comprar com esse
inteira vai jovem com gta5 vem cuidando
do e 66 e vem com lego star wars e
depois ainda tem o pac 2 que uma
playstation do inter vai com gente assim
também o drive clube e como as as
inscritas só se inscrito e ézio
collection' a vossa gênero dizer que não
estou nada pois só ficam já sabe que na
final 32 petrópolis passem por lá
qualquer pessoal vamos lá entrar então
no clima de tororó por isso é bom ter um
vermelho
existem várias coisas que 321 vai nem
décimo vídeo temos um zumbi do fórum rio
de 2011 a campanha fugir no mato já que
a fuga no meio do mato
como é que isso foi um jogo bom é que o
mesmo vai defender o telemóvel youtube
[ __ ] quando juntos lisboa no próximo
vídeo de ieds demetri project também
2011 tem a ver com droga é droga faz o
teu cérebro um faz a voz dela com um
pulso
ela culpou o forte impulso outro não só
de imaginar o meu povo escutado cara e
se está tudo era muito não não só vai só
vai avançar sua obra só oito desespero
seu time eo ir ou baby a screen em 2012
eu acho que é esse eu já vi este já
visto vai começar com menos o a colher
méxico isso os clipes gastador
[Música]
ouvi um barulho do choque a totó que
foram buscar dentro da entrada dentro da
alma a alma eo e estendemos quer ou não
isso ainda
[Música]
que medo olha eu sou ruim deu nisto
exato frame eu penso que vai julgar a
alma depois ainda tem que o sorrisinho
assim vai pra cima e nem risco é que ele
é meio sorriso com com sua e não sei tá
muito estudo na próxima próxima próximo
vamos lá pessoal próximo vídeo eo
youtube google phone sorriu 2011 só que
esta é que é a mesma empresa que fugiu
do sumbe né sorriu
ok já começa no parque de estacionamento
já já não cheira bem já vai para superar
essas da lei do gênero oposto theo é 90
lojas até próximo vídeo número 6 mental
health
só em 1999 entrou em uma loja e joga
duas delas está no número 5 2010
o outro não precificam anúncio o já
começa num ato montanha russa no mato
eu quero muito poder eu quero andar
nisso crédito foi divertido anunciou que
a montanha russa
ai ai ai cara vai ter fila para votar
possuí-lo 1 ao fim tal esse ponto como a
resort tipo para atribuições então é
isso não é esse então o exterior e deu
pra perceber né meu é o da playstation
que não dá não dá pra perceber número 4
spyder audi rs4 2005 aqui estão no fundo
um carro né
aranha 81 bizarros isso não viu nem todo
mundo vai dar boston vai por si maranhão
ó vai por cima e gigante do gato aletéia
pelo treinador ganha um carro da música
a música de areia
o woody é muito grande para o efeito tal
belluco toma muito o que se anuncia tipo
carro virou maranhão a enviar um caso
singular rap
o bê evitou o 3 sony playstation 3 2006
este percentual não visto sequer ouvir
eu acho que já vi isto não se já bonecas
que começa a falar né
a gripe a ea eu acho que já está no rio
para muito gripe e se tudo isso eu sei
que foi banido no egito foi banido de
dentro do olho e pegou o goleiro yong
pizarro pra [ __ ] é muito bizarro olha
aí número 2 cara daqui fim 1998 até este
antigo este antigo excitador estão
felisa a eu acho que já sei qual é este
eu acho que tem um susto aqui
ainda na ponta tem um susto eu sabia
porque eu sabia eu que eu conheço eu não
sou muito boa e isso não sei o que sou
ozzy do norte sinai creche que o suco
café isso né dons em mim
koff frio foi uma perda energética e só
pessoal top um denunciador júnior men
maps do ano 2000
olhe a parte assustadora pra [ __ ] aí
sei se é boneco de vodu meu
[Música]
ambos chutando muito floresta para o tal
perfil que susto maps uma garrafa de
vodka
o que é qualquer coisa para uma vida né
[Música]
clélio o corpo ouviram o cabeça 4 vezes
não pode ser sempre queria voltar a
encantar surpreender o médico né
soubesse sobre isso vem estou já
enfatizado já foste já está utilizando
por quem for forte
[Música]
então é só vamos ficar aqui com espírito
espero que tenham gostado e comentei
embaixo quando o anúncio que vocês
acharam tempo mais botafago mesmo pelo
notw afaa estão treinando para fazer
hoje vocês têm aqui estes dois filhos
que provavelmente não viram tanto podem
ler e aqui em cima
vocês podem se inscrever se forem novos
aqui no final é que és o aluno mina
todos fiquem bem e até a próxima